وهكذا ، فإن [موسيقى] تنتقل من أغنية حقبة الحرب الأهلية للمغني اللبناني العظيم فيروز ، وهي أغنية مؤلمة من الخسارة واليأس ولكنها لم تهزم سكان هذه المدينة ، فقد شهدوا انهيار الاقتصاد الذي عانى من اضطرابات جائحة فيروس كورونا والآن هذا الآن هو ليس الوقت المناسب لتأليف نعي بيروت في حي كارنتينا المجاور لميناء إيدي باراداي وابنه إصلاح تمثال مادونا المكسور أخبار وفاة بيروت مبالغ فيها إلى حد كبير إنها تحتضر دائمًا ويعتقد الناس أنها تحتضر ولكن هذا ليس صحيحًا أنها ستظل دائمًا نرتقي ، سنرتفع دائمًا للانفجار الذي أصابته أضرار بالغة أو دمر آلاف المنازل وسبل العيش ، وقتل ما يقرب من 200 وجرح أكثر من 6000. تدل الندوب من هذه الكارثة عميقاً سمحال الخطيب تظهر لي غرفة نوم أطفالها باستثناء الجدار الذي ترفض تسليم لبنان إلى السياسة. القادة الذين دفعوها إلى الأرض ، لماذا يجب على أطفالنا الهجرة ، تسأل الآن يمكنني حزم أمتعتهم والمغادرة ولكن  لماذا يجب أن نترك هذا
البلد للمحتالين
واللصوص بينما هم يشاهدوننا دون
ذرف
دمعة واحدة ولا دمعة واحدة.
هل سنقف مرة أخرى
هذه
الأرض أليس هناك تقول سونيا مشيرة
إلى السياسيين
هذه الأحجار ليست
ملكهم إنها أغنية فيروز لنا تنتهي بكلمات أنت
بيروت
هي ملكي عقلك يحتضن